I'm Kosta, and I run
Pinnacle Stone Restoration.
We are specialized in
restoration of terrazzo
and natural-stone surfaces.
I'm going to walk you
through how to restore
over-100-years-old terrazzo
that is covered in carpet.
The most difficult part
of this restoration
is carpet and glue removal.
We remove carpet with
electric scraping machines.
It also can be done by hand,
but electric scraping machines
do much faster and a better job.
The project is taking place
in a historic university dormitory.
The client decided to
restore existing terrazzo
rather than replacing carpet,
'cause carpet accumulates
a lot of dust and bacteria.
Generally, terrazzo is
indestructible surface.
Also, it's an easy maintenance.
We are discovering multiple
issues with this terrazzo.
Carpet glue, missing terrazzo,
surface cracks, and gouge nail holes.
It's repairable but
requires a lot of work.
The next step, we are
removing carpet glue.
We are removing carpet glue
with handheld scrapers,
versus using grinding process.
When we use a grinding process,
we can activate the quality of the glue,
and it will become sticky.
But by hand, we keep the temperature low,
and then glue, it just comes
out very easy from terrazzo.
Then we grind terrazzo floors
with grinding machines.
We use diamond disks.
We use coarse, medium, and fine grits
to flatten terrazzo.
It's very important to level
and flatten terrazzo
floor for honing process
and before polishing process.
In this particular project,
we are going to use a
dry-grinding process,
just because we want to see the process.
During the wet-grinding process,
the slurry that is produced
during the grinding
prevents us to see the
details of the terrazzo.
After grinding process is completed,
we're left with multiple
nail holes and cracks.
To prepare them for patchwork,
we approach each like a dentist,
and we clean them out like a cavity.
Then aggregates go into the holes.
And when it cures, it will
be ready to be ground down,
to flatten, and to level it
to the existing terrazzo.
The next step of restoration
process is honing,
which is done with diamond pads.
We use water, of course,
to lubricate the diamonds.
So, lowest grit will be 50 grit,
followed by 120, 220,
400, and 800 grit.
What honing process does,
it ensures that no scratch is left behind
the grinding process.
Since it's the wet process,
it will accumulate a lot of slurry
that has to be extracted by wet vacuums,
followed by edge work.
So, edge work is the area that
bigger machines don't
reach, those tight areas.
So every step has to happen
with handheld machines
in a smaller scale, grinding
process to honing process,
to reach those tight areas
to develop the same sheen
as rest of the surface.
The next step is a polishing.
As 800 grit completes the honing process,
1,500 grit starts polishing process.
So, 1,500 grit followed by 3,000 grit.
And after that, we use DIP systems.
This is much finer diamond pads.
When you polish terrazzo,
you're increasing the density of terrazzo,
so it becomes more durable,
because you're closing those pores.
That automatically makes
terrazzo harder and more durable.
And now it's time to seal.
We're using microtopping sealer.
It's more like impregnating sealer
that goes into terrazzo,
and it prevents terrazzo from staining,
and it protects it.
The last step is burnishing.
Burnishing helps sealer
to bring the terrazzo
to its highest sheen.
If I had to compare this project
to other projects that we've done,
I would say this stands
for No. 10, for sure,
because there are a lot of obstacles
that we have to go through.
And the terrazzo is original.
And I have to mention that this is about
5,000 square feet.